can't do much better than michael jordan
apparently you can
if you ask isaiah thomas right mike you
can take this one i i'm entertained by
this endlessly
well i mean you know this first of all
consider the source it is isaiah thomas
we know there's no love lost there that
said
a man zeke told sports illustrated
that when it's all said and done
lebron
will pass kareem
as the goat
so yeah let's focus on the latter part
of that statement we'll get to lebron
whether he can be the goat you know in a
second but the person he's passing on
zeke's list is cream of duo jabar and
like first things first mike that's not
a hot take that's not a that's not a
unique take that's not an unusual tape
because the kareem is underrated or
overlooked in the goat conversation
commentary is so common now until he's
not
overlooked or underrated in the gold
conversation because everybody brings
them into the conversation whenever
we're having it
yeah but you know mike they bring him
into the conversation
it sounds good
it all sounds good and they say hey look
at these numbers what you see these
numbers here
which are tremendous for kareem six mvps
and six championships
and they and they cite all the reasons
why kareem is in the conversation
yet
after that conversation he falls out of
the conversation again and i think part
of it i look
i i think when you talk about the
greatest of all time you almost have to
have a few different categories it's
just natural it's a natural bias for all
of us all of us say let's say all of us
under
six eight
if you're under six eight
uh and you look at great players it's
hard to appreciate somebody yeah seven
feet tall or over or or taller as kareem
is seven two and just to appreciate
their dominance you almost need
chamberlain stats and by the way
chamberlain doesn't come up as much as
he should either a guy averaging 50 in a
season 100 points in the game on and on
it's just hard for people to go there
with all-time centers i think there
needs to be so
you go perimeters and bigs
you go perimeter
yeah yeah
because you know we always we go in the
same places and go uh you go jordan and
lebron gets in there magic gets in there
but it's hard for people to appreciate
kobe gets in there it's hard for people
to appreciate kareem and that
unblockable skyhook
uh that he had and all the things that
he did and he dominated and and really
go back his career he probably has
the greatest basketball career
oh hi anybody
power memorial oh my god oh ucla
i got some old school finger waggers out
there saying oh yeah oh you can go
forget about bill russell you'll feel
about 11 championships in 13 years and
two two championships in san francisco
and an olympic gold medal what's wrong
with you but once again
uh it's an era thing and it's a center
thing it's hard for them to get
recognition but let's talk about can we
can we can we do some diagnosis so can
we do some cycling now before we do that
before we do that
before we do that i won't get back i
want to stay on kareem just for a second
i want to stay on korea because it's
like
it's it's not it's not the wrong answer
it's not my answer for who's the
greatest you know i'm a jordan guy
obviously i started a show that way um
and i'm on record um as saying that
there's nothing lebron could do to pass
jordan in my mind because for me it's
not about the number of championships
um and look truth be told i'm not old
enough to remember louis alcindor i'm
barely old enough to remember kareem
abdul-jabbar
um
so it's it's unfair in a lot of respects
because
you know you have a lot of people who
didn't actually watch
kareem or before him wilt and bill
russell
in real time and now and we're basically
relying on old video stats you know so
there's there's a an inherent bias for
those of us who you know the generation
before me grew up with magic and larry
bird that's why i tend to lean more
toward mount rushmores in these
conversations just because it's the easy
way out you know it allows you to get
more people in i struggle with them my
rushmore to be honest with you but for
me my mouth rush more would be
jordan
kareem
um
russell
and that fourth spot
that fourth spot i i i kind of like i
rotated i know my rushmore is permanent
that's the problem about rushmore is
it's permanent you can't change it
because it's like at one point you know
i would have had you know i would have
had magic up there you know and then or
trying to get magic and bird in there
somehow is it lebron now is it kobe so
you know mount rushmore's make it a
little bit easier to give these people
their just due or even all-time starting
fives because you're right trying to
pick one goat when those when they did
such different things by by the nature
of their positions
and in different eras
it's really hard i told you i've never
defaulted to the to the 6-0 in the
finals thing because don't tell me 6-0
is better than six and four you know
because that means you went ten times so
magic won five and lost four he went
nine times i mean look how many times in
a row no less that lebron went to the
finals it's something to be said for
that versus just going undefeated in the
finals
you know i think and this kareem thing
is so interesting you're right i think
another thing that factors into it and
this is not just with kareem i think
this is the era as a whole
kareem when he got to milwaukee
i mean he dominated immediately and wilt
was wilt was a little shook by him wilt
couldn't stand him because wait a minute
there's somebody there's somebody new
because wilt had to deal with bill
russell and bill russell blocked him for
all the all those years and just as bill
russell retires here comes this kid and
he's just he's dominating immediately so
wil used to really uh used to get up
for for kareem and did everything he
could even in his later years did
everything he could to play his best
games against kareem but the bigger
story is i think the 1970s in the nba
they're often overlooked because you
didn't have david stern as a
commissioner then uh you didn't have the
lucrative tv contract that you got when
stern came into the league and they
timed it up with magic and larry had
east coast west coast
and you've heard the story before mike
you know when the celtics won the
championship i think in 1981
byrd's first championship
the game was on uh or the year before
80. magic game you know the 42 point
tape delay so he's getting it done game
six and and the nba was kind of like an
afterthought in the tv space
and i think a lot of those players get
lost and the other thing is kareem
wasn't always nice to people
you know he he wasn't always
yeah and i don't know i okay that should
not matter i i think that's what you
know i know i know what you're saying i
just maybe i'm trying to give people the
benefit of the doubt to hope that they
don't hold that against him because his
resume
laid out
is is is above is above something it's
as petty as that i mean he's the most
decorated player of all time um when you
put together you know his stats and his
championships and like you said going
back to every level of basketball but
that point about him not being nice to
people is interesting because
you know should we
as we evolve as a society evolve slowly
as a society
you know how much do you factor in just
in terms of your affection and
appreciation you know
uh and i don't mean to muddy the
conversation but how much do you factor
in somebody's off the court influence
because
the way i would connect lebron and and
kareem is that lebron in many respects
took him a little longer but in many
respects
is a modern-day kareem in terms of his
off-court presence his voice his
activism i mean kareem was 19 years old
when he was at the cleveland summit
next to russell and jim brown wow
um
you know he was participating in
protests at ucla
and and the voice and the activists
that he's remained throughout his life
the author
um
the spokesperson
the the advocate for justice
before it was popular you know and so i
look at lebron and i feel like lebron he
has truly taken that torch
which i don't know if anybody carried it
but as as well between kareem and lebron
he's taking that particular tour no
answer is no and right away
they didn't yeah and and i think you
think you bring up a great point uh
about kareem just the the totality
the all the things that he's done i i
remember one writer saying uh very well
about kareem he said you know most
sports writers
wanted to be athletes
but kareem was the athlete who wanted to
be the writer he was that rare guy and
so he is he's extremely prolific
uh in the literary space so add that
everything everything that he that he
means to support so so who is your goat
who is your goat then i don't know if
i've got a straight answer for you in
terms of right now right here right now
you need one right now
yeah give me one who's the answer all
the time
yeah
nobody's gonna hold you to it you know
the facts change so can you yeah she
will yes she will you gonna hold me too
no no i won't i'll tell you why i won't
hold you to it once you give me an
answer i'll tell you why i won't hold
you to it
um
bill russell
okay
why were you reluctant to say bill
russell why were you reluctant to say
that you look like you had a hard time
getting that out why but well because
because all right because the
championships mean
because that will sidetrack the
conversation i'm gonna put a bookmark
i'm gonna say bill russell and then
bookmark because when i started talking
about the championships you're going to
say what you said before that shouldn't
factor into it but that's just me guys
that's just me
okay but that's not that's yeah that's
just also he is also one of those guys
who it was beyond basketball it was 1113
but it was it was social justice it was
speaking out it was
doing things before it was popular to do
it yes in boston massachusetts a lot of
people get it twisted
they get this twisted and it's important
this is an important distinction
because they'll say hey bill russell
he had a problem with the celtics he had
a problem with boston no he had a
problem with boston
but if you ask him
i remember talking to him that's name
dropping but so what as a matter of fact
not only that i talked to bill russell i
was once in a this is one of my favorite
stories i was once in a limo and if i
had a presence of mine i should have
challenged everybody
uh in in roxbury as we were driving
through to a three-on-three game
because it was me bill russell and dr j
in a limo just talking okay
all right how great is that but he once
said that playing for the celtics was
like heaven for him like he just enjoyed
playing for red and his teammates did
not enjoy the city but he enjoyed the
celtics
you